thanks for having me and thanks for the
very nice introduction and it's nice to
be back at stanford after two years so
and this is actually my first academic
travel ever since the pandemics right so
that i feel very excited to talk to a
live card rather than just my computer
screen so and today i'm going to talk
about object skills and uh the quest for
compositional robot autonomy so as
jeannette introduced i started my
faculty at ut austin and i found a new
lab called rhubarb
perception learning lab there at ut
austin and so today what i'm presenting
i really the first batch of work from my
own student right so i should start by
first saying that uh i'm probably very
proud of my students work and especially
during this
very difficult time and uh because i did
this amazing work that i got the chance
to hear talk about them all right
so let's get started
uh one of the most exciting news i think
in the robotics world recently comes
actually from the outer space right so
maybe some of you already know that
james webb space telescope is now
successfully launched and the following
operation so to me this is really a
remarkable progress of uh robotic system
engineering right so out of the
thousands of different tasks to be done
there are 300 of them a single point
failure that means that if any of these
300 times fails the entire telescope
will fail as whole and also because this
is in outer speed there's no way that we
can send a technician to go fix those
bugs
but still
this is a ginormous effort it takes
over nine billion dollars of internal
money and a huge team of engineers and
scientists working together for 20 years
but in the end it was a great success
and it was successful
so just seeing this news kind of makes
me wonder that
apparently humankind has already figured
a way to be extremely complicated yet
highly reliable systems but why
we see from the news and
meet social media that uh
autumn's driving cars and personal
robots are always five to ten years away
well one of the key reasons is that we
need a generalist robot to sense and act
in the real world and it is kind of
difficult to program and design this
robotic system in the traditional form
of system engineering and that's why our
research on robot learning come into
picture right so it offers a new
paradigm to design robotic behaviors
with ai and data driven techniques that
are otherwise like hard to manually
engineer
typically when we do group learning
research
the workflow is like this right so we
have a small team of researchers and
faculties and work together bring some
ideas and this is actually showing me
doing research with some of my my
stanford colleagues when i was still
here um and we come up with idea and
then we kind of implement the modeling
our favorite framework let it be pytorch
tensorflow jacks and then we try it on
our robot platform if we get a decent
success see
70
80 success and beat all the baseline of
our choices we're pretty happy about it
and then we write a paper and we get a
publishing top conference and then we
move on
and then when we move on to the next
work it is very often that uh the next
paper will not build upon the prior ones
right so there's no effort taken to get
that 70 success to the
99.99
reliability for real-world execution
so we see a dichotomy here on one side
we know the drill of how to build really
complex it's reliable special purpose
body system like the space telescope on
the other hand we see that uh
ai powered robot learning has become a
new paradigm to kind of design and
generate purpose robotic behaviors in
the world
um but the lack of reliability of this
learning methods is really preventing us
from widespread deployments so naturally
we are asking
can we combine the best of both worlds
so on one hand we have this rigorous
engineering principles to design complex
and the reliable system on the other
hand we can have the robot learning and
techniques and they developed like
recently to encourage like a general and
robust behaviors and that's exactly what
argue as the key to achieve deploy
vulnerable autonomy in the wild
so to think about what exactly other
kind of engineering principles that we
can learn as a robot learning
researchers i think there are two
principles that inspired
my research our research a lot that are
abstraction and the composition what is
abstraction abstraction con
concerns about the division of labor if
we give you a very complex system of
very hard problems how can we break that
down into some simpler pieces so that we
can work on this individual sub problems
in isolation
and what about composition
is a one way piece together this
individual modules right and how can we
make sure that this individual modules
work in harmony in coordination with
each other towards this
shared and overarching goal
so our recent research has been looking
at how can we kind of embrace this
engineering principles for building
complex robotics systems in building
general purposes of autonomy in the
world so if you take a system
perspective to look at robotics
generalist robots
that is a complex system that sends an
act right so there's a sense into action
loop that the robot receives the
perceptual information from the
environment using its on-board sensors
and processing information to determine
what the action to take and then the
action in turns generate new sensory
stimuli for the next times this stream
making
and
a straightforward way to model this
sensing action loop is direct mapping
right so from sensory data to uh motor
actions if you take a computational
perspective this is a very non-linear
complex function that we can learn and
this is indeed what
like this end-to-end
deep learning approach has been
exploring sometimes we call it a pixel 2
torque that would learn a direct mapping
from the raw sensory data to motor
combined and this has been achieving a
lot of
great progress and
impressive demos in recent years but
more and more we start to see the
shortcoming of this approach in the kind
of the high data requirement the high
sample complexity as well as the british
generalization
so instead of seeking this
pixel to torque approach or
like a research investigator how can we
embrace the principle of abstraction and
composition in particular how can we
learn state abstractions from the raw
sensory data how can we learn the action
abstraction from the low level motor
control and once we establish these two
abstractions we're able to build more
robust like a making modules that
achieve a higher level of robustness and
generalization and i call this the
compositional robot autonomy stack
so today's topic or talk about the kind
of concrete research problem we've been
looking at like in the overall theme of
a compositional robot autonomy stack
in particular we look at how can we
build
understand unstructured things as a
composition of the objects present in
the scene and
how can we understand the robotic
behaviors as a set of
like a skills or reputable of skills
such as grasping pushing reaching as a
building blocks to synthesize long-term
robot interaction
and as an early showcase of this
compositional paradigm is our work on
neural task programming that i did a
while ago with some of my stanford
collaborators here where the high-level
idea is to interpret a long-term robot
execution like say a long-term
demonstration sequence of a robotic task
into this hierarchical program such that
a complex procedures like stacking a
bunch of color cubes can be recursively
broken down into simpler pieces like a
stacking a bunch of color cubes can be
breaking down to
picking
a bunch of pick and place actions and
then each peak and place can be further
decomposed into picking and placing and
then eventually the pick and place got
mapped to some lower level eps that can
be directly executed on the robot and
with this
the objects in these domains are the
color cubes on the table
the skills are picking and placing and
we show that with this object and skill
abstraction we can achieve
a higher level of generalization that uh
once our model is trained we can apply
this to generalize to unseen block
configurations that never appeared in
the training set so that's much better
than the end-to-end approach that we
demonstrated earlier
but there's a catch here
that for ntp the objects and skills are
clearly defined right so and
very often the cases in empirical study
of the compositional approach we find
that this type of composition modeling
typically works really well if we have a
clear notion of a finite set of objects
and
and skills and to model so in the block
word and the
if we're doing a bunch of picking and
placing on color pubes it makes it so
easy once the compositional structure
will emerge but really the question is
how can we unblock the block work right
so pun intended here so when it comes to
real world what are the kind of complete
set of objects and what are the
completeness like set of skills to model
in order to really operationalize this
compositional approach that is a kind of
fundamental questions in many research
domains that we kind of sweep that under
the rug and that we assume that the
object and skills are given
um that makes it easy to build this
compositional approach but really i
think uh these are the kind of really
fundamental questions to really take
advantage of this compositional modeling
so
like what is the object what is the
skill right so this seems uh a trivial
question from the first look but the
more you think the more you research you
you find that
the more you know the less you know so
really the questions and the focus of
today's talk is to really understand
what is the object and the skills to
in
unlock this type of compositional
modeling in the autonomy stack in
particular i'm going to talk about got
two lines of work on learning object
abstraction and skill abstraction so
instead of seeking a universal
definition what's the true definition of
a skill and object we're going to study
this
in a pragmatic approach i'm going to
study the operation operationally in
concrete problems in robot learning such
that hopefully by studying this is what
gives us good intuition what other
object and skill representation are
useful and necessary for building
general purpose robot
so
for the first one i'm going to
look at like a learning object
abstraction from embodied interaction
and then we're going to move skill move
to skill abstraction at the second part
okay so
we study object representation first in
the task of a robotic grasping
um
why robotic grasping it's very important
like a
first like skill to learn to unlock a
lot of real-world applications like
assembly logistics smart warehousing etc
where the input we're assuming is like
partial point cloud of the entire thing
and you want to determine the grass pose
and grasp orientations to execute the
grasp
our intuition uh data if you look at
objects how can we kind of characterize
a real world object there's different
perspectives like drawing inspiration
from human cognition we can describe an
object like a mug what make a mark on
mug based on its visual attributes right
so
what makes a mug a mug is because it
looks like a mug you have an empty
inside it has a curvy handle so when we
recognize this visual appearance and we
we see this is a mug
and an alternative way to look at how we
characterize attribute objects is based
on their functional properties
although
no matter how the marks looks like and
the mark is the mark because we can use
it to grasp it
from the handle and also it can hold
water that we can drink from the mug so
based on this different um
characterization of objects it requires
different type of understanding of the
object geometry versus object affordance
affordance means the functional
properties of the objects
and so our insight is that the object
affordance understanding and geometry
understanding are not too isolated
problems so when it comes to like
encoding object information and building
object representation they're really the
two sides of the same coin so just to
use this example to illustrate like the
intuition if we think about how to grasp
this mug from this partially observed
view you see that
there's a handle that's like a partially
occluded if we want to grasp this mug
from this view if a robot can
reconstruct this mug from this partial
view it will help it determine the
precise grasp location grasp orientation
to
to to be able to grasp the mark
successfully and once the was able to
pick up the mug and that actually
confirms the 3d reconstruction right so
it tells us that there's indeed certain
3d geometry that exists in this occluded
area so it goes the other way so
that means that there's some kind of
synergistic relationship between the
understanding the geometry like 3d
reconstruction and understanding the
functional properties being able to
grasp the object
so we built giga to capture this
intuition which stands for graphing by
implicit geometry and affordance where
the idea is to learn a shared object
representation through a 3d backbone and
the train for both types of object
avoidance and the 3d reconstruction so
that the learn object representation
encodes the object information from both
dimensions
so
the question first question uh we need
to
answer is what is a good representation
for the object things that encodes
afford and standard 3d geometry so
motivated by advances recently from 3d
vision and graphics community we use the
newer fields for 3d sync what is a
neural field right so it is a
coordinate based neural network that
maps some input feature like a visual
feature of the object and also a chord
coordinates in the cartesian space xyz
to some quantities at that location
where the quantity can be the sign
distance function or the occupancy at
that location
why do we like about
neural fields is because that uh by
encoding the 3d shape as part of neural
network parameters it allows us to
develop this smooth and continuous
representation of the of the things that
we can query the
coordinates at arbitrary resolution and
also because this is a distributable
layer so we can plug that in as part of
a bigger network and train with a rich
source of supervision so that encourage
learnings to like give rise to the
meaningful representations from
different sources of training data
so that's the key idea we have the
neural fields as a backbone and
to really operationalize this idea we
start with tsdf that's something we can
get from the depth camera on the robot
and then we perform convolution to map
this input tsdf into a structured
volumetric feature grid
from this feature grid we can at each
location we can get a local feature by
pulling from the grid and doing some
interpolations to get that local feature
at a particular point and based on the
local feature and graph center we can
predict the
the graph quality graph grip orientation
on in that like a grade print center and
also we can query the 3d geometry like
the occupancy probability at the
location
and then by training both grasp
affordance and the 3d reconstruction
with this shared structure feature
grades it encourages information sharing
so to be able to encode the objects in
both different properties
and to actually train this model we use
a cell supervised procedure so the way
we do that is we dump a large rich set
of like a 3d off objects into simulating
environments and we sample like a
variety of our grants candidates as you
can imagine that if we're doing random
sampling some of them will lead to
success other for leads to failure right
so that will give us a data set of
positive and negative data to train the
affordance prediction without any human
supervision
okay so to show how this works and uh
kind of qualitatively on the robot and
this is achieving a standard performance
on the task of six stop grasping in
cultural environment and typically in my
lab when i asked my student to do real
reward experiments i asked them to show
me the
uncut video right so this is just
showing you that a 10-minute continued
execution of robot here is ethan he's
putting a bunch of objects into the
scene and the running continuous for 10
minutes you can see that some of the
graphs like a fails occasionally but
overall it it has like pretty consistent
performance in
being able to picking up object from
culture and then like drop them into the
beam
okay so
encouraged by this result so we try to
understand why exactly giga works and
what exactly the object representation
learns all right so because we are using
this implicit neural representation on
your fields we can actually query the
affordance as arbitrary locations in the
scene so by corey the location densely
it allows us to map the 3d thing into
this
kind of beautiful uh heat map and called
affordance landscape basically showing
what is the grasp quality or like grass
success likelihood at each individual
locations where the red one means higher
affordance like more likely to have a
grass success the
like the white one or gray ones are low
affordance scores right we see that uh
compared to vision the former state of
art and our method was able to generate
more diverse graphs and especially in
those alkali occluded locations and to
show you qualitatively how that
comparison looks like vgn fails at two
consecutive trials on picking up the big
object we see that a giga actually first
like pick up the small object from
behind because they it knows that the
p-cap this object actually
is like less likely to incur collision
so it was able to
declutter this thing successfully
so um then we kind of gotta take a step
further to see what exactly is a 3d
shape like a that's encoded in that
representation so the way we investigate
that is we have a 3d reconstruction
branch right so we can
read all the 3d shape and you can query
that occupancy property at different
locations from margin cube to extract
mesh from it and we can actually
visualize the mesh and do comparison and
we compare giga with two different
variants one is only training with
affordance one is only trained with a
grasp supervision and then our final
model trends on both we see an
interesting result that uh the the giga
representation that trend
um the grasp affordance uh actually pay
more attention to the graspable part of
the thing than the non-glass bubble part
which can kind of make sense if you're
looking like the 3d reconstruction with
only the 3d reconstruction uh
supervision it sometimes meets some
geometric details like the handle of the
mug because it's really a thin part of
this thing but
when we train with the grasping
supervision it acts try to reconstruct
something right so in the grasp of parts
like a handle does not have to be super
accurate but it knows that there are
some 3d geometry in the scene and on the
other hand we see that the giga
supervision actually ignores some of the
part of thing that's less relevant to
the grasping test for example the bow
before training 3d reconstruction it
learns to grasp the bottom of the bow
but it is not a grasp of a part so once
we see we trained the jointly it was not
uh like a grasping that bottom part of
the the bow so
that's that's giga what we learned from
it all right so we use this idea of a
joint learning affordance and uh
and the 3d reconstruction to develop a
steve art performance uh in sixth of
grasping and as object representation it
has the following properties first
this is task dependent meaning that the
operator representation is learned from
a downstream task for optimizing the
graph success so as a result the learned
representation actually dynamically
allocate its representative
representation resource to the part of
the things that's most relevant to the
task and we see from the 3d
reconstruction result show you earlier
it is multimodal it tried to capture
like a different aspect of the object
properties i have 3d
shape versus like affordance and
and it captured the synergies between
these two right so learning affordance
actually
improved the 3d reconstruction on the
grass bubble part and conversely and
doing the
3d reconstruction helps grasp
in those like a partially occluded area
it is a structured we combine this
conventional like explicit structure of
a volumetric feature grid with this
implicit neural representation based on
neural fields and the entire of the
representation is self-supervised
meaning that it's learned from the
embodied interaction of the robot by
doing this kind of
trying to error with a grasp candidate
without any human supervision
some questions um
yeah so this is really interesting work
i'm wondering um the affordances um are
they influenced by the context of the
scene as well
at all or or is that not or are these
objects basically treated individuals
the question is like if the affordance
are affected by the context of the thing
yes because we are occurring this local
feature by pulling the representation
from the neighboring feature grid it
actually takes into account the context
information
in the neighborhood right so that's why
this example of the
small bottle for example being picked
first in that initial video
yeah and then i was wondering um
i guess there are lots of works out
there that do
pick in place right from clutter and
it's really hard to compare them
uh because of maybe different data they
are using or just um
how to reproduce them right locally
so how do you
uh you you because you talked about
state of the art and i'm wondering like
how do you kind of encompass all this uh
landscape of work to good question how
do we do like actual proper benchmarking
right so here uh most of the quantity
results we report an actual based on
simulation that we use the same
simulation as the prior work and so that
we can make sure that we have the right
the standardized like protocols yeah
doing real-world evaluation as you can
imagine is a lot harder to standardize
based on different settings hardware
objects and lighting conditions and all
those
and
so you train on sim data
do you have any sense of
the sim to real gap here uh
so when it comes to grasping symmetrical
transfer is either when we are using
dapps information actually we use psdf
it's the actual process that's
information that really narrows like
domain gap allows zero shot transfer
with some kind of a proper data
augmentation noise injection
if i'm doing semantic grasp with rgb
rendering will
enlarge the domain gap right so that's
what makes the transfer harder so i
think that's what requires new tools and
better rendering better digital
augmentation techniques to further close
the gap okay yeah thank you
i was curious uh maybe a similar
question
right now this is all with the parallel
jaw gripper do you see
like this would easily extend to much
more complicated grasping like hardware
or would it be very hard because of the
simulation challenge
yeah so um the cell supervises the
procedures and allows as long as you can
like sample random grasp with like uh
the other morphologies but as you can
imagine if we're moving to dexter's hand
like so sampling valid grasp with like
complex mythology for what dealing with
like much higher dimensional action
space right so that's what could
potentially create difficulties so one
needs a better pliers to make sure that
we're actually simple valley grass with
different robot hardware
right now the scenes are only composed
of graspable and movable objects i'm
wondering like what will happen if there
are
immovable parts for example if there are
is a shelf in the scene we haven't
configured that we assume that all the
small objects are movable
yeah
like 3d reconstruction as well as the
affordance view
well i can imagine if we really have
like environment fixtures and once you
sample random grasp there it will not it
will give up negative affordance labels
so the network might be able to figure
that out but we haven't tried that this
we assume that all the objects are
graspable from now
get there
do you like measure anything like
out of distribution
um
yeah so
like a
good question i mean if you look at the
results simulating deformable objects is
really hard right so and though we are
using a rigid body simulation it's
really expensive to simulate the
deformation in general but you see that
the model was able to kind of
grasp the deformable object and all the
objects here are not in the training
that because there's
some random objects that we find in the
lab
um yeah so i have a decent performance
on generalizing to unseen objects good
question
okay
so
that's that's giga um
so it's kind of encouraging that we see
that like this object representation can
be learned from in body interaction
right so it kind of motivates us to take
a step further to think
can we actually use this interactions to
build models of objects that capture the
environment properties that's in
independent from the interactions see
look at this two objects and if i try to
pull the door and imagine like how the
door will move
all right you can sort of guess it and
based on your plier but
it's only until like you pull them and
you see that they are actually quite
different kinematic structures right one
is the revolute joints and that is the
prismatic joints so it's kind of
interesting to see that whether we can
observe
the physical interactions of the object
in the real world and use us to create
evidence for us to learn objects and
create digital twins by digital training
i mean the
virtual copy of the the the same objects
in the real world so that we can spawn
them in virtual world for
same physical simulation and in the
fashionable languages uploading those
physical objects into the metaverse
right so
that's kind of the settings very
interesting um the concrete approach
similar to
similar to the structure implicit
representation we use in giga we use
that to process the input pawn club
before and after the interactions and
that we call this approach detail that
stands for
digital training of articulate objects
if you play pokemon you know what detail
is okay so it opens the uh
part level geometry and the three
illustrate and and also like a 3d
segmentation of the parts and also the
articulation parameters so just to
illustrate how the workflow looks like
so it start by taking the um like pawn
cloud observations from the iron hand
camera and then it can interact either
by human or by the robot and then look
at the thing again after the interaction
this gave us the evidence to create this
interactable digital tree by interactive
digital training we mean that you have
this object segmentation geometry and
the articulation properties in place so
that we can actually represent this
object in some standard 3d format that
we can import in a physics engine for
simulation and
for detail to work it does not assume
that we know the object category a
priori and also it works on two type of
joints like prismatic versus versus
revolut
so
why do we care about digital twin it's
about is that this type of digital
training create recreation actually
paves the road for us to narrow the
reality gap so that we can observe the
interactions of physical objects in the
real world and then use this to recreate
this the same object in physical
simulation and the reason we like
simulation is because we can leverage
like a data driven text in general like
a very
huge amount of cheap data to train
robots to
learn manipulation behaviors with this
object and here we are using a
simulation framework that we developed
in in my lab called robot suite and then
we can take the uh
manipulation behavior back to the real
world for execution right and then this
new manipulation behavior further like
generate new sensory stimuli for us to
learn more knowledge about the object
so overall the detail gives us a
a way to build interactive models to
learn the environment property of
objects that form from invited
interaction and we show again that uh
being able to physically interact with
the object emit new information for us
to better understand look at different
aspects of objects and again we show
that uh this structured representation
allows us to jointly encode different
object properties like their geometry
and the articulation and uh again the
idea of creating digital twin allows us
to kind of like bridging the simulation
and the real world in a tight loop so
that we can go from
real world to simulation and back to the
real world uh through this digital twin
creation
okay so
that's the kind of the first part i
thought i should probably stop stop here
and see any questions
i think
wait on my microphone
um i yeah maybe i
blinked or maybe i missed it but where
was the model how you uh did the digital
twin creation like i was just wondering
about oh okay okay i haven't showed them
like i i guess i blanked yeah or maybe
you didn't show up that's kind of a
technical detail i didn't go over it
does some kind of a point cloud
processing use some cross attention
the key is really established
correspondence between before after
interactions right it's how the pawn
cloud moves okay and then we use this to
decode with this implicit neural field
representations yeah
okay and so the articulation decoder do
you
how do you assume like
a set of possible mechanisms like a
prismatic and revolutionary assume
there's two and there's like first a
classification to
determine the type versus like it's a
binary classifier and then
based on that we have a
another decoders to output the actual
parameters under that articulation type
okay great thank you
okay so
now i finish talk about object
representation let's move on to to to
scales all right so
what is skills so skill is
highly ties to the notion of a
compositionality so compositionality
is a multiple word but it's also a very
hot topic these days in machine learning
and many people many machine learning
researchers believe that capturing the
compositional structures of real world
phenomena let it be language of videos
or robotics task execution is really the
key to achieve systematic
generalizations with modern machine
learning tool so a lot of the seminal
working compositionality come from
language and
logics and semantics which they
investigate how the sentence of the
meaning of the sentence emerged as like
a composition of a bunch of words in it
and drawing a parallel we like to study
compositionality uh in the context of
robotic execution think about a task
like pre-print dinner how can we
gradually break that down into sub parts
like washing dishes cooking food and
then further decomposing into like a
more primitive actions like picking
pushing grasping and we call this bottom
up bottom level constituents of the
behavior as like sensory motor skills so
these are grounded on raw perception
that are temporarily extended so um with
temporal abstraction
so if you look at compositionality and
the philosophers investmentation
linguists have spent a lot of time like
understanding what are the principles of
a compositionality so looking at those
it really gives you lots of insight so
overall there's kind of two ways of
looking at this one is the context
principle saying that the really the
meaning of the word hinges on the
context of the other words like
surrounding the word in the in the same
sentence right so the exact meaning of
bark kind of like it depends on there's
a
the yellow dog bark at the cat right so
the yellow dog and the the cat can't
influence the meaning of the bark on the
other hand there's like the
compositionality principle seeing that
the meaning of this sentence is a
function of this individual parts in
that case like dog cat bark have their
own meaning and when we piece them
together that can like give rise to the
meaning of the sentence so
which one is correct with wrong is wrong
this is still open debate right so we're
not going to argue which one is the
compositionality principle uh is is
truth but uh instead we're going to
leverage these two principles and
investigates in the context of
compositionality in the robotics context
so this leads to our work first bus
which stands for uh bottom up discovery
of sensory motor skill that uh we start
with a bunch of like unstructured
task demonstrations where the goal is to
extract this words from the sentence and
the drawing analogy here is going from
the task demonstration to a set of
sensory motor skills that we can use as
building blocks to synthesize like a
long-term robot interaction to solve new
tasks and once we have this library of
skills we can compose them with a meta
controller to
synthesize long-term interaction and we
want this to be realistic and deployable
to real hardware so we want to make sure
that this work is scalable we do not
require human temporal annotations and
the skills operate on raw sensory data
so
concretely how about work is first by
building a hardcore representation of a
task demonstration it goes from the
bottom all the way to the top but
recursively group like a neighboring um
temporal segments into one based on
their similarity where the similarity is
measured by some multimodal or
multisensory statistics so we go all the
way to the top and apply this algorithm
clustering procedures and from this
hierarchical tree structure we can
extract the
recurring temporal segments so these are
the temporal segments that keep
repeating in your data sets and then we
use them as the training set of skills
so to illustrate the workflow we have
the temporal tree structure that we
extract the temporal segmentations and
then we compute some feature
representation of those individual
segments and we put together like all
the temporal segments from like the task
demonstrations in our in our data set
and this demonstration can be collected
for
like a variety of our task skills and
this allows us to map the robotic
behavior into this latent space that we
can do a clustering
procedure to identify the different
partitions of the behaviors in that
latent space
from this just give us like a training
set for k different skills like if we
are running a gaming class string and
that partition the space by k copies and
then this gives the data sets for us to
train for case sensory motor skills that
we can actually use the data for um goal
condition imitation learning to train
these skills and once we train that we
can
compose this with a metacontroller to
invoke the skill by like a
predicting the
skill id like which skill to invoke as
well like the setting the sub goal for
those skills to achieve that this way
allows us to like uh invoke those skills
to solve tasks and when we train the
metacontroller and again use some like a
supervised imitation learning objective
that we can learn from a dataset without
drawing error
so to show this actually gives like a
quite capable like a um
solutions to learn like a sensory motor
controllers to solve reasonable long
horizon tasks that if you don't have the
temporal hierarchy or modeling it's
really hard to struggle to to learn and
the entire model is trained quite
efficiently with handful of
demonstrations collecting certain
minutes all the time
and there's kind of interesting
observations from this uh this
experiment first we showed that uh
by grouping and building this hardcore
task structure based on multiple uh
modality or like a multi-sensory cues
like multiple
views of images and also the pro
perception actually leads to better
tasks and skill segmentation right so
this allows us to discover better skills
to be composed and
for solving tasks so this kind of
resonates some of the seminal study in
event perception a lot of work done here
in stanford like by uh barbara trevetsky
that uh like so human actually leverage
this multi-modal cues and to perceive
the boundaries of events
and we show that uh by discovering and
learning those skills from multi-task
demonstration although those
demonstrations are not necessarily
collected for the same task by kind of
identifying these recurring patterns and
the training on those data they actually
give rise to more reusable more
generalizable skills so that uh uh
leads to uh higher task performance
compared to
skills if are only like discovered from
the task specific demonstration
and also uh because like the skills are
discovered for multiple tasks and they
have the good versatility and
generalization that uh we can reuse them
for novel tasks by freezing the skills
as apis and only train a high-level meta
controller to invoke them in a new
combination to solve new instances of
tasks
and to show you how this works as we
said that uh we want to put minimal
assumptions so that it does not rely on
human
manual segmentation and uh like in 30
minutes of demonstration were able to
train the robots to perform this long
horizon task on the real robot so
everything was done from growing up from
images and to the motor control with
imitation learning approach
so that concludes buzz right so it's a
bottom-up approach to discover a set of
reusable skills from task demonstration
um we showed that uh leveraging
multi-sensory cues and being able to
discover the skills from multi-task
demonstrations and improve the diversity
of data and as a result by training
those improve the quality of the skill
and by exploiting this skill and the
meta controller type of a hierarchical
design it give rise to a sample
efficient learning algorithm to learn
complex behaviors using handful of
demonstrations
okay so
take questions
how did you do the clustering in the
feature space or like were there a lot
of was there a lot of tuning required or
was it easy to find very different
clusters
um
how how much does that have an effect on
the end goal
good question so for the classroom what
we do is for each of the temporal
segments we compute a feature based on
some multi-modal representation learning
actually that exactly work is what i did
with ginette and there was michelle lee
and jeanette in the icar 2019 on how to
learn like a cell supervised multi-modal
representation we use this
representation as some signature of the
temporal segmentation and then we group
them
so the grouping actually we're using a
classical like a clustering method
called hierarchical algorithm clustering
it's pretty simple method to find two
closest uh like a temporal segments in
in the neighborhood and then combine
them into one
but uh the exact algorithm that we use
is kind of orthogonal right so
if we have a better clustering algorithm
that we can plug that in in our
framework and in the paper we actually
com compare with like different choices
like k-means versus spectral clustering
versus this and this is the one that is
the most effective in the setting
generally related like a follow-up
um
so you have this representation and you
do this unsupervised clustering i guess
right but is there any
what
what is the supervisory signal at the
end to say like oh yeah that's a good
cluster or is that not that kind of
supervision signal is that not there
yeah so
there's no human supervision which means
that the discovered there's a give and
take if you are doing unsupervised
completely there's no guarantee that the
discovered skill actually carry like
semantic meanings but the reason that it
was able to produce sensible segments is
because that uh in a
manipulation procedure by looking at
like the multi-sensory statistics and
it can actually give some hints on the
structures of the task if you're doing
like so pack insertion before and after
you touch the packet right so
the actually the correlation between the
like a multi-modal sensory data changes
like it's like statistical pattern so by
using this multi-sensory contingencies
and that is like the kind of supervisory
signal that we are trying to harness to
build this consistent house structure
okay yeah and
is it how do you pick k
again a good question so uh that's a
higher that's a hyper parameter we
choose right so
somehow in the paper we said six is the
best uh
so we have a cross validation and it was
kind of a bell-shaped curve um
this i think is like a problem dependent
right based on what is like the
diversity of the task and also like the
complexity and so forth so yeah that's a
that's a hyper problem to change
okay so that's
the first part of the compositional
modeling and back to
uh this this slice on compositionality
in language and the behaviors right so
what kind of boss was doing it kind of
resonates with like the context
principle seeing that we first give you
a bunch of tasks and i want to extract
the skills as like the kind of the the
building blocks like the basic
constituents of the tasks so you can
imagine it's like drawing a parallel to
like it from sentences to words so now
we are like looking at the opposite
direction if we are provided with a a
set of like skills a priori uh like a
reaching grasping pushing can we use as
the building blocks to scaffold like
long horizon and complex robotic tasks
so that leads to maple which stands for
manipulation primitive augmented
reinforcement learning so in maple we
look at we already given a set of
heterogeneous uh library of skills the
reason we call heterogeneous is because
this skill might operate at different
time temporal resolution and take
different arguments to instantiate their
execution for example grasping can be a
skill right so the way we call grasping
as functional apis we specify the graph
center and the grip orientation
why this is a good idea to use like a
skills well if i'm doing reinforcement
learning you know there's other word of
robotics there has been been decades of
research building special purpose
robotic behavior modules right so
there's grasping there's a motion
planning there's like a dynamic movement
like a
primitive et cetera so can we actually
take advantage of this decades of
research and in robotics and to use that
as a building blocks for behavior and
this modules are typically very well
understood they generalize well and they
have like good performance guarantee
so that's the key idea but the one
special thing that we did is that what
if the libraries that we built is
incomplete it cannot express the entire
space of possible robotic behavior so we
add a additional token or additional
primitive called autonomic actions
that's typically what reinforcement
learning algorithm use as their action
space right so to fill in the bank in
case like some behavior cannot be
expressed by the the rest of the library
so that's the key idea that uh we train
reinforcement learning now we use this
uh library as the underlying action
space so the policy actually outputs the
primitive type and also the parameter
arguments to instantiate those
primitives and then execute this
primitives to interact with the
environment and then once the
primitive finishes and it returns back
the observation and the rewards and so
that we can move to the next stage of
decision making
when we do it other way
kind of implement a hierarchical policy
that uh uh
first select the primitive and under
that primitive and the way determines
the the argument that the whole thing
can be trained end-to-end with some
software to critique this method
so
to just to kind of illustrate the idea
we kind of compare maple with a bunch of
baselines and you can find more in the
paper uh we first showed that atomic
actually if we're just using the like a
bare metal low level control and it
won't succeed there's really struggles
for the exploration challenge
and uh
compared to maple we show that it's also
necessary to include those uh uh
primitive uh atomic actions because if i
do impact insertion there's a certain
like phase of the task that requires
some really contact reach interaction
like the insertion phase right so it
needs some very precise and dexterous
manipulation behavior it's really hard
to model in the primitive that we have
as limited so we see that it was able to
invoke those atomic primitives to fill
in those gaps and
actually we kind of by composing those
primitives and the maple unveils the
innate compositional structure of the
task so by analyzing the execution of
what the primitive is like each time it
can actually be this kind of wordle like
task sketch any of you playing wordle so
you know that uh there's a
squares means like the type of primitive
it's like each time and then we can just
try roll out the policy under different
initialization
and then this kind of generate this what
we call a task sketch as like the
scaffold as some kind of a signature
representing the kind of the
structures of the task so why are we
interested in that well for example like
this pack insertion task we see that
first it involves the grasp primitive to
firstly pick up the pack and then call
reach to try to inch forward and towards
the hole and then in the insertion phase
is use the atomic actions to actually
does the insertion
so by analyzing the
task sketch and under different
instantiation different randomization we
can actually have some kind of
quantitative sense of the
compositionality of the task that's
actually what we did like for a variety
of uh robotics manipulation from simple
lifting stacking pick place to like more
contact-rich ones like assembly and an
insertion that we see that uh
it makes intuitive sense like for for
block word and the stacking picking
place and the
often the cases only the high level
primitive like picking placing and
reaching i invoke to fulfill the task
and the task sketch has a very good
consistency across different
randomization and and uh but uh for more
contact reach and task that requires
physical interaction often the case we
see that it's a lot more variable in
terms of the task structure
and another benefit of using this
primitive is that it can effectively
abstract away a lot of look at the low
level dynamics mismatch between
simulation and the real robot if we have
a good implementation of a grasping
module or motion planning module right
so we can
effectively train our models in physical
simulation and then deploy that in the
real world so this is in both domains we
are using a post estimator first to
detect the object pose and empirically
often we find that transferring a
post-estimation model from simulation to
real world with aggressive randomization
is a lot easier than transferring into a
policy right so by doing this and
training the policy on that like a 3d
pose and it allows us to achieve this
real robot transfer okay so to conclude
this we talked about how can we use a
heterogeneous set of primitives to
scaffold the lung horizon robot
manipulation and uh the idea is to
develop develop a hierarchical policy
that selects the primitive from the
library and instantiate its behaviors by
like specifying the arguments of the
functional apis and we show that by
doing this we can analyze the innate
structures of the composition
composition structure of the task
contingent on the primitive we have of
course the more primitive we have and
it's likely to change our composition
representation of the task depends on
the versatility and reusability of the
task
so um
these are the four works that i covered
so far what we learned okay so we first
talked about what is the skill what are
the object representation that we want
to learn that i talked about giga and
detail showing you that the object
representation we care for fulfilling
robotic tasks are often context
dependent and task dependent so we can
actually learn effective actionable
representation from
downstream task supervision and
it's often a good idea to capture the
multimodality of the uh the object
properties and the multifaceted and like
very often we see synergistic
relationship of understanding the object
from different perspectives
and uh we show that uh in body
interaction with the objects and is a
powerful source of supervision that
allows us to learn this perceptually
grounded action-informed information
from the interaction
and what is a skill we investigate like
the context principle versus
compositionality principle was going
from task to skill another is the
opposite direction from skill to task
and we
one of the key like a
property to build effective skill is
their expressiveness their versatility
and also their reusability in different
contexts in different tasks and of the
key here is to build temporal
abstraction to reduce the challenge of
modeling the low level actions and the
fine is the
and also we want to make sure that the
learning skills are perceptually
grounded that can operate on raw sensory
data
so to kind of put this in a bigger scope
remember like at the beginning i
mentioned like so how do we combine the
comp engineering principles and two
modern rebound learning approach that uh
uh to achieve this i argue that we
really need to combine like the
methodologies from different views and
historically um building ai architecture
for rural autonomy so in the classical
pipeline naturally we are embracing the
principle of abstraction right so we
divide this entire stack of pixel torque
into a separate separate problem of
perception planning control there's
vision committee work on perception
planning community work on planning
control
community work on control and that
didn't really talk to each other and
what's the problem with this is it
creates this inf information bottleneck
between the modules right so there's
going to be compounding errors
throughout the stack and deep learning
eventually throughout the stack and
replace this with an end-to-end
trainable neural network but we start to
see limitation on the high data
requirements and also limited
generalization
i think um a promising like new frontier
is really kind of like combine the
complementary strengths of different
ideas right so
well we can still use the kind of
restructured priors and inductive bias
in individual learning modules like the
perception planning control as a black
as the
as the individual function or
decomposition of the stack but at the
same time we can couple them together
with object representation the skill abs
representation as the state action
abstractions so that we can enable full
stack optimization
so that's the vision well going forward
and
i'd like to acknowledge my students who
are doing this amazing work for my talk
and
have to take more questions
[Applause]
thank you yuki are there any questions
either in the room or in the zoom room
as well if you're on zoom you can unmute
yourself and ask a question if you like
so something that was very exciting was
in the second half of the talk the first
part of that you showed with the buds
uh that you're getting like 70 percent
success on
that was really good
and then in the next part we showed 100
success on the peg insertion cost
so
do you think that the
i mean it's clear from the way you
presented that bringing these two things
together should really improve cost
success but is there anything missing or
is it just like maple plus buds and
you're done
it's maple and plus like about a buzzer
is done
not really right so and i think there's
definitely things that will
uh simplify a lot of internal object
variations like you are seeing that we
are evaluating maple on a lot of like
simulation environments the
visual stimuli is still quite sim
simplistic compared to the real world i
think like so when we move to actual
real world settings so we need to bring
better models to process like on the
vision part as well so definitely like
just combining these two is not the end
of the story and also how do we actually
build models that can
continually interact with the
environment discover new skills and need
like like a keep adding new primitives
and new abilities to the library right
it's
likely that it is not going to be a
one-day job we can like this completes
that we are done with that so we need
some continued learning never ending
learning and to really kind of kick in
the loop
more questions
okay i have one question oh sorry was
there someone on zoom no
no okay i have one question so in the
beginning you showed this
engineering paradigm with like the
telescope and hundreds of people
and then you showed this general robot
with three people
and you talked about combining those i'm
wondering what happens if you just add
more people to this
well in some sense like adding more
people has already tried right it's not
that well lack of manpower in working on
those generalistic systems and there's
also driving car companies and in the
industry robotics companies has been
also have big teams of engineers and
scientist working on that so
well
people is one
aspect of the the puzzle but i think so
like a better methodologies and better
algorithms and
being able to be open-minded and see
that when
well as i like about learning
researchers sometimes we hear
engineering and the systems we kind of
like that's something that would be
little right so that's something that we
don't like that's a sign of incremental
uh
improvement but i feel like being more
uh open-minded and embrace those
principles and really look at the
problem as from the system perspective
is the way to go so yeah again it's not
just a people problem but also um
new method and new insights and are
needed to enable that next level
take it to the next level
okay
all right so thank you very much yuki
for coming also in person to
thank you for being part of the invite
yeah be part of this stanford robotics
seminar after two years
so thank you everyone for coming and i
see you next week on friday
[Applause]
you